اظهرت مشاهد مصوره جثامين 14 شهيدا معظمهم
من الاطفال قضوا نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي
على منزل يؤوي نازحين شرقي رفح جنوب قطاع
غزه الليله
الماضيه واطفال
ونساء
قبل
[موسيقى]
استشهدت هدول نسايبي اح انا كنت نازح
عندهم من البريج للزوا ولما طلبوا منا
نرحل من من منطقه صلاح الدين من الزوايده
ما كان سكناهم رحلنا كليتنا لعند المعبر
تفاجانا بالليل اللي هم بيضربوا البيت
بشكل مباشر انا كنت بعيد عنهم شويه ما كنت
معهم في نفس البيت
لانه البيت اللي هم قاعدين فيه ما بعنا
كليتنا العائلات يتها تفاجانا ضرب ضربوه
بالف
16 الاطفال كانوا نساء كل واحد بمرته
باولاده 14 شهيد من عائله ابو
لشين هيها الطفله هذه الطفله هذه شو عملت
لهم شو سوت لهم طفله ماتت وهي جوعانه
ماسكه الخبزه فيد هيها جينا نطلع الخبزه
من ايدها ظلت ماسكه بادها الخبزه شو سوت
عادي عملت عملت مشاكل لاسرائيل